You know that you love your cat, but does your cat love you back? Cats have long had a reputation as standoffish pets, especially compared with dogs. What many cat owners will tell you that the cat human bond can run deep. In recent years, research on cat behavior has begun to back up that intuition. Scientists are studying the relationships we form with our cats and are gaining new insight into cats' social and cognitive abilities. They're finding that cats may be. be far more socially smart than they usually get credit for. So how do researchers study cat psychology?
你知道你爱你的猫，但你的猫也爱你吗？长期以来，猫一直被认为是一种冷漠的宠物，尤其是在与狗相比时。许多猫主人会告诉你，人与猫之间的纽带可以非常深厚。近年来，关于猫行为的研究已经开始支持这种直觉。科学家们正在研究我们与猫之间建立的关系，并对猫的社交和认知能力有了新的认识。他们发现，猫在社交方面的聪明程度可能远超人们通常对它们的评价。那么，研究人员是如何研究猫的心理学的呢？
How do we know whether our cats are as emotionally attached to us as we are to them? What about individual differences among cats? Why do some cats love to play with humans while others prefer to hang out under the bed most of the time? How much of those differences are due to nature and how much to nurture? Finally, how can you use what researchers are learning about cat behavior to make your cat's life better. And of course, how can you train your cat not to scratch the couch?
我们如何知道猫是否像我们依恋它们一样在情感上依恋我们？猫与猫之间的个体差异又该如何解释？为什么有些猫喜欢和人玩耍，而另一些猫却大部分时间更喜欢躲在床底下？这些差异中有多少是天生的，又有多少是后天培养的？最后，你如何利用研究人员在猫行为方面的新发现来改善猫的生活？当然，你该如何训练你的猫不去抓沙发呢？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Kristen Vitale, an assistant professor of animal health and behavior at Unity Environmental University, where she studies domestic cat behavior and the cat human relationship.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是联合环境大学动物健康与行为学助理教授克里斯汀·维塔莱博士，她专门研究家猫的行为以及人与猫的关系。
She received a PhD in animal science with a focus on experimental psychology from Oregon State University. She also spent time as a visiting research fellow at Kyoto University in Japan, where she conducted cross-cultural research into cat human social interaction. Her research has been published in many peer-reviewed journals and covered by media outlets, including Science Magazine, National Geographic, the BBC, and the New York Times, as well as the Netflix documentary inside the mind of a cat. Dr. Vitale, thank you for joining me today. Great. Thanks for having me.
她在俄勒冈州立大学获得了动物科学博士学位，主攻实验心理学。她还曾在日本京都大学担任访问研究员，在那里进行了关于人猫社会互动的跨文化研究。她的研究成果发表在许多同行评审期刊上，并被《科学》杂志、《国家地理》、英国广播公司、《纽约时报》以及Netflix纪录片《猫的内心世界》等媒体报道。维塔莱博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。太棒了，谢谢邀请。
Let's start with this reputation that cats have for being standoffish and independent, especially when you compare them with dogs. You've done some research that's found that cats actually do form strong emotional connections to their humans. Can you tell us about that research? Yeah, well, we've got kind of a few different studies that basically show this idea that this whole idea that cats are standoffish and aloof is kind of just a myth. One of these studies was basically looking at the sociability of cats, and we ran basically
让我们从猫被认为冷漠和独立的声誉开始谈起，特别是当你把它们和狗比较时。你做过一些研究，发现猫实际上确实与人类形成了强烈的情感联系。你能给我们讲讲这项研究吗？是的，我们确实有几项不同的研究，基本上证明了猫冷漠疏离的这种观点其实是一种误解。其中一项研究主要是观察猫的社交能力，我们基本上运行了
the exact same experiment that had already been done with dogs. And we look at how a cat reacts to a person, basically how long they're going to spend near to them. And we saw that cats spent basically equivalent amounts of times with people as we saw with the dogs. So what we see is that there are some cats who are very, very social and spend almost all of the time with people. Some cats who are somewhere there in the middle, they spend some time with people, but not the entire time. And then we've got cats with lower sociability who spend basically no time with people. But this is really the same distribution that we see in dogs.
与之前在狗身上进行的完全相同的实验。我们观察猫对人的反应，基本上是看它们在人身边待多久。我们发现，猫与人相处的时间与我们观察到的狗与人相处的时间基本相当。所以我们看到，有些猫非常非常善于社交，几乎所有时间都和人在一起。有些猫处于中间地带，它们会花一些时间与人相处，但不是全部时间。然后我们还有社交能力较低的猫，它们基本上不花时间与人相处。但这实际上与我们在狗身上看到的分布是一样的。
Not all dogs are hypersocial the way that's kind of been presented. So really that distribution and sociability is not that different between dogs. dogs and cats. And in terms of attachment, that bond that cats and dogs display toward their owner, we're really seeing basically the same styles of attachment in both dogs and cats. And they're the same styles of attachment that we actually see in human infants as well. Are cats that easy to do experiments on? I mean, will they cooperate when you're trying to get them to do things? Yeah. So, well, one thing to consider is some of the tests we run, you don't really need the cat to do anything besides what they're already going to do.
并非所有的狗都像人们所呈现的那样具有超强的社交能力。所以，这种社交能力的分布在狗和猫之间并没有太大的不同。在依恋关系方面，即猫和狗对主人表现出的那种纽带，我们实际上在狗和猫身上看到了基本相同的依恋类型。而且这些依恋类型与我们在人类婴儿身上看到的实际上是一样的。猫真的那么容易进行实验吗？我的意思是，当你试图让它们做事情时，它们会配合吗？是的。所以，有一点需要考虑的是，我们进行的一些测试，你并不真的需要猫去做任何事情，除了它们本来就会做的事情。
So, for example, that sociability test I mentioned, the cat doesn't have to do anything. If they choose not to come spend time with the person in that circle, that's just a zero score for sociability. If they choose to spend 100% of the time in the circle, that's their choice. So some of these tests we do, we don't really force the cats to do anything. We just put them into situations and see how they react. But then there are some tests where it's more of that discrete trial, such as something like a point. assessment where you point at a location, have the cat approach, reset them, put them back behind the start line, have them approach again. And we do find with those kind of like repetitive
例如，我提到的那个社交测试，猫不需要做任何事情。如果它们选择不来那个圈子里和人待在一起，那社交得分就是零。如果它们选择100%的时间都待在圈子里，那是它们的选择。所以我们做的一些测试，并没有真正强迫猫去做任何事情。我们只是把它们放在特定的情境中，看看它们如何反应。但也有一些测试更像是离散试验，比如指向评估，你指向一个位置，让猫靠近，重置它们，把它们放回起跑线后面，让它们再次靠近。我们确实发现，对于那种重复性的
trial type tests that not all cats will participate in that kind of thing and will have some cats drop out. But that's actually something we're looking at right now is, well, why do some cats drop out when dogs, for example, might do very well with that kind of testing methodology? And part of that could be differences in life experience that we're giving dogs and cats and not really species differences, rather how we're treating these animals. Those of us who have had both cats and dogs kind of have a sense so that dogs are trying to somehow please their humans and cats really don't care. I mean, is that the case?
试验类型的测试，并非所有的猫都会参与，有些猫会中途退出。但这实际上是我们目前正在研究的问题，即为什么有些猫会退出，而狗在那种测试方法下表现得很好？这部分原因可能是我们给予狗和猫的生活经历不同，而不是物种差异，更多的是我们对待这些动物的方式不同。我们这些既养过猫又养过狗的人，有一种感觉，那就是狗似乎在试图取悦它们的主人，而猫真的不在乎。我的意思是，情况是这样的吗？
Well, you know, I don't think we can really say that from a scientific perspective. You know, is a dog trying to please their owner or are they trying to resolutely? receive a reward for doing a behavior that they've experienced in the past. And that's not to say, you know, dogs are, you know, not attached to their owners or anything like that, but not every motivation to, you know, do a trick or do a behavior is because the dog is trying to please the owner. It could be because they're trying to, you know, earn a reward. And with cats, we find that most people don't train their cats. And so there's not kind of that history of re-enroll. enforcement between the owner and the cat. And I think that is playing a bigger role in what we see
嗯，你知道，我不认为从科学的角度我们可以真正这样说。你知道，狗是在试图取悦它们的主人，还是它们在试图坚定地获得奖励，以执行它们过去经历过的某种行为？这并不是说狗没有依恋它们的主人，或者类似的事情，但并不是每一个做把戏或行为的动机都是因为狗在试图取悦主人。这可能是因为它们在试图获得奖励。对于猫，我们发现大多数人并不训练它们的猫。因此，主人和猫之间没有那种强化历史。我认为这在这些差异中起着比猫和狗的内在品质更大的作用，如果这说得通的话。我想我们的一些听众可能会惊讶地发现，竟然还有猫心理学家这种职业。你是怎么进入这个领域的？从事这种研究的人多吗？是的，进入这个领域的过程有点疯狂。我的背景非常跨学科。我的背景实际上是生物科学。我本科读的是动物学。然后我转到了环境科学，研究环境如何影响户外猫的社会行为。从那里，我继续攻读动物科学博士学位，师从心理学家莫妮克·尤德尔博士。那才是我真正获得
these differences between cats and dogs, more than just inherent qualities of cats and dogs, if that makes sense. I think some of our listeners may be surprised to learn that there's such a thing as a cat psychologist. How did you get into this field? And are there many people doing this kind of research? Yeah. So it was kind of a wild ride getting to hear. I have a very interdisciplinary background. So my background is actually in the biological sciences. I did zoology for my bachelor's. And then I actually moved into environmental science where I studied how environment impacts the social behavior of cats living outdoors. And then from there, I progressed to my PhD in animal science where I worked with Dr. Monique Udell, who is a psychologist. And that's really where I got
心理学训练的地方，特别是在实验心理学方面。实际上，我们所做的是探索猫的思维，什么因素影响它们的行为，它们如何感知社会伙伴，它们的社交能力是什么。至于有多少人在做这个，我不会说有很多人在做，但确实有一些。特别是在日本，正如你提到的，我去了海外，在京都大学的心理学实验室学习。那里有人在做这类工作。所以我不是唯一一个，但这相当少见。你认为关于猫的研究少得多，是因为科学家觉得它们没那么有趣，还是因为它们更难研究？或者是其他原因？
my psychology training, especially in experimental psychology. And really, with, With that, what we're doing is exploring the minds of cats, what factors impact their behavior, how they perceive social partners, what their social abilities are. And in terms of how many people do this, I wouldn't say there's not a lot of people doing this, but there are some. Especially in Japan, I, as you mentioned, went overseas and studied in the psychology lab over at Kyoto University. And there are people over there doing this kind of work. So I'm not the only one, but it's fairly uncommon. Do you think there's so much less research on cats because scientists find them less interesting or harder to study? Or is it something else?
我认为有几个因素。我确实认为猫很难相处或无法训练的观点已经进入了科学界。事实上，在我读博士的前几年，有一位猫研究人员接受采访时说，金鱼比猫更容易相处，这给人一种猫太难相处的印象。但这并不是我的亲身经历。所以我认为这是一个原因，就是那种刻板印象。它们很难训练，很难相处。另一个我认为是资金问题。我认为很多人看到了资助狗研究的好处，因为狗可以担任工作角色，
I think there's a few factors. I do definitely think that idea that cats are difficult to work with or they're untrainable, that kind of has found its way into the scientific community. And actually, a few years before I did my PhD, there was an interview with a cat researcher who, said, you know, goldfish are easier to work with than cats and kind of gave off this idea that cats are just way too difficult to work with. But that really hasn't been my experience with them. So I think that's one part is just kind of the stereotype. They're difficult to train, difficult to work with. Another one, I think, is funding. I think that a lot of people see the benefit to funding, especially dog research, because, you know, dogs can be in working roles.
我们可以让它们作为牲畜护卫犬、炸弹嗅探犬、服务犬。狗研究可以资助的效用范围非常广泛，我认为人们在猫的研究中并没有真正看到这一点，但我认为这种情况现在开始改变了，特别是在情感支持动物方面，
we can have them as livestock guarding dogs, bomb sniffing dogs, their service dogs. There's a whole wide range of utility that dog research could potentially fund that I think people don't really see in the catwork, but I think that's beginning to change now, especially with things like emotional support animals
以及猫越来越多地参与动物辅助干预。所以我希望这种情况开始改变，人们会越来越多地开始研究猫并资助这项工作。我们这些养过猫的人都知道，它们有独特的个性，如果我可以用这个词的话。有些很信任人，有些很胆小，有些很粘人，有些很冷漠。你认为这在多大程度上是天生的，多大程度上是由于猫的成长方式造成的？是的。对于个性，我们基本上可以说那是相对稳定的行为特征，
and cats being involved more and more in animal-assisted interventions. So I'm hoping that some of this is beginning to change and people are going to more and more begin studying cats and funding that work. Those of us who have had cats know that they have distinct personalities, if I can use that word. Some are trusting, some are fearful, some are cuddly, and some are aloof. How much of this do you think is inborn versus due to how a cat is raised? Yeah. So with personality, we can basically say those are relatively stable behavioral traits
个体表现出来的。所以猫确实有个性。它们绝对是个体，有自己独特的行为。那么，其中多少是天生的，多少是生活经历造成的？我认为是两者的结合。我们知道，只有几天大的小猫在它们的窝里就已经表现出差异了。所以从一开始，小猫在几天大时行为就不同了。但随后我们看到，随着猫的成长，生活经历在小猫天生拥有的那些初始行为特征的基础上，进一步发展了那种个性。所以生活经历在猫的个性发展中确实起着巨大的作用。再说一次，个性是相对稳定的。所以即使在人身上，人格特质也会随时间改变。但我非常感兴趣的一点是，经验对动物行为，特别是猫行为的影响。我们确实看到了对猫的巨大影响。所以对于那些可能正在养猫或考虑养猫的听众，有一种正确的社交化猫的方法吗？是的，尽早开始。我们知道小猫在两到七周或两到八周龄之间处于社交化的敏感期。这意味着在它们生命的那个阶段，小猫对了解社会伙伴特别敏感。所以它们接触其他猫、其他物种、人类、狗，并获得积极的社交，以及与多个不同的人以多种不同的方式进行社交，这一点非常重要。我们知道，缺乏这种社交经验的猫是未社交化的，在以后的生活中会对人表现出很多恐惧。我们实际上称这些猫为野猫。它们没有对人进行社交化。
that an individual shows. So cats definitely have personalities. They're definitely individuals with their own individual behaviors. Now, how much of that is inborn and how much of that is life experience? I think it's a mix. We know that kittens only a few days old are already showing differences within their litter. So already off the bat, you know, kittens are behaving differently just at a few days old. But then we see as cats progress, that life experiences kind of build off that initial,
狗身上也发生了完全相同的事情。如果狗在生命中的那个敏感期没有进行社交化，它们也会害怕人类，并且不会表现出社交化的狗行为。所以对于这两个物种来说，生活经历和社交化，特别是在早期，是非常重要的。让我们谈谈更大范围的差异。正如我们所说，你在日本花了一些时间进行研究。猫的行为会因国家而异吗？人类文化会影响猫的行为吗？日本的猫是什么样的？它们和美国的猫不同吗？是的。我们在美国和日本的家庭猫和猫咖啡馆的猫身上都进行了研究。
those initial behavioral traits of kittens born with to really further develop that personality. So life experience does play a huge role in developing personality for cats. And again, personality is relatively stable. So even in people, personality traits can change over time. But one thing that I'm very interested in is that it's the, impact of experience on animal behavior and cat behavior specifically. And we do see a huge impact to cats. So for listeners who might be getting cats or thinking about getting cats, is there a right way to socialize a cat? Yes, start early. So we know that kittens are in a sensitive period for
我们还调查了这两个国家的公众和主人。我们发现，美国的猫，无论是家庭猫还是猫咖啡馆的猫，都比日本的猫更善于社交，这非常有趣，社交能力显著更强，与陌生人和主人相处的时间更多。在公众认知方面，我们发现总的来说，美国人对猫作为宠物的看法比日本人更积极。但尽管有这些差异，对猫的依恋程度并没有显著差异。所以尽管猫的行为有显著差异，但两国的主人对它们的猫都有强烈的依恋。所以这非常有趣。这是我们希望进一步研究的东西，以真正弄清楚
socialization within two to seven or two to eight weeks of age. And what that means is that that's a time of their life where kittens are especially sensitive to learning about social partners. So it's really important that they are exposed to other cats, to other species, humans, dogs, and that they receive positive socialization as well as socialization with multiple different people in multiple different ways. And we know that cats that lack the socialization experience are unsocialized and will display a lot of fear toward people later in life. And we actually call these cats feral cats. They're unsocialized to people.
到底是什么因素导致了这两个国家之间的这些差异。回到猫的社会认知能力，它们能在多大程度上理解我们试图与它们交流的内容？例如，猫知道自己的名字吗？当我们指向某样东西时，它们会像狗一样看过去吗？是的，实际上，在猫身上研究的许多社会认知特征与狗身上的相匹配。我今年夏天刚做了一个关于猫和狗认知特征比较的演讲。猫在同一水平上表现出许多相同的能力。例如，指向，猫会像狗一样很容易地跟随指向到一个位置。它们甚至会跟随更微妙的线索，比如你注视的方向。
And the exact same thing happens with dogs. If dogs are not socialized during that sensitive period in their life, they also will be afraid of humans and not display socialized dog behavior. So for both species, life experience and socialization, especially early on, is very important. Let's talk about differences on a broader scale. You spent, as we said, you spent some time doing research in Japan. Does cat behavior vary by country? Does human culture affect cat behavior? What are cats like in Japan? Are they different from cats in America? Yeah. So we conducted research on both cats living in houses and cats living in cat cafes in both the U.S. in Japan.
就像看向一边或另一边，猫会跟随那个非常微妙的线索作为方向信号。它们能够察觉我们的情绪状态、我们的心情。它们能够根据我们自己的行为调整它们的行为。所以，是的，猫有很多能力，再次强调，它们正在与狗的表现相媲美。多年来，我们只是认为猫没有这些能力，但我们只是没有研究它们以观察它们是否存在。几年前我曾在动物收容所做志愿者，我被教导如何接近狗，你不要直接看着它们，你要从侧面接近它们。我认为我在纪录片《猫的内心世界》中发现的一个非常引人入胜的描述是，你可能用来与猫交流的慢眨眼。那是什么？它们在回应什么？人们为什么要那样做？你该如何最好地接近一只猫？是的。慢眨眼是这样一种观点：当你非常缓慢地闭上眼睛，然后缓慢地睁开时，你是在向你的猫发出信号，表明你心情愉悦，而你的猫可能会将其解读为一个建立纽带的时刻。所以你的猫可能会对你慢眨眼。目前除了显示慢眨眼的猫似乎更有可能从收容所被领养的研究外，关于这一点并没有太多的研究。所以我们对那种交流方式了解不多，
And we also surveyed the public as well as owners in both country. And what we found, was that cats in the U.S., both cats living in homes and the cat cafes, were more social than cats living in Japan, which was very interesting, significantly more social, spending more time with both a stranger and with their owner. And then in terms of public perception, we found that in general, people in the U.S. view cats as pets more favorably than people in Japan. But despite those differences, there was no significant difference in level of attachment to the cat. So owners in both countries were both strongly attached to their cat despite the significant differences in their cat's behavior. So that was super interesting. And it's something we're hoping to study further to really get
但至少在人类这一端，对猫的慢眨眼做出回应似乎确实有些道理。但就接近它们而言，你真的想慢一点，就像你谈论狗时说的那样。你不想从头顶上方接近。你想慢一点。在触摸它们之前让它们闻闻你，对于猫和狗来说，嗅觉是一个非常重要的感官。所以它们想能够闻到你。它们可能会蹭你。这确实是一个关键，就是让猫来主导互动，而不是你抱起猫开始抚摸它们，伸出你的手，让它们闻一闻，看看它们是否蹭它，如果是的话，摸摸它们的头，看看它们如何反应。嗯，很多猫会接受这一点，它们可能会
out what are the exact factors that are causing these differences between the two countries. Switching back to cat's social cognitive abilities, how much do they understand of what we're trying to communicate with them. For instance, do cats know their own names? Will they look at something when we point at it like a dog will? Yeah, actually, many of the socio-cognitive traits that have been studied in cats match those in dogs. I actually just presented this summer on a comparison on cognitive traits in cats and dogs. And cats display many of the same abilities at the same level. So, for example, pointing, cats will readily follow a point to a location the same way as a dog. They'll actually even follow more subtle cues such as the direction of your gaze.
翻身并要求更多的抚摸，但其他猫可能会通过后退来回应，这是一个它们结束互动的信号。所以这很大程度上又是关于理解那种个体差异，观察那只特定的猫如何对互动做出反应，并调整你的行为作为回应。所以我有一个来自美国心理学会同事的问题，她在英国长大。她说，在成长过程中，普遍的感觉是让猫有自由在户外漫游更仁慈。但在美国，许多人认为最好把猫养在室内，因为这样更安全，也能保护我们日益减少的鸣禽种群。有一个正确的答案吗？猫最好是室内猫、室外猫，
So just like looking to one side or the other, cats will follow that very subtle cue as a directional signal. And they are able to pick up on our emotional states, our moods. they're able to adjust their behavior in response to our own behavior. So, yes, there's many abilities cats have that, again, they're rivaling what dogs are doing. And for many years, we just thought cats didn't have these capabilities, but we just weren't studying them to see if they were there. I was involved in volunteering at an animal shelter a few years ago, and I was taught how to approach dogs, and you don't look at them directly and you kind of come at them from the
还是这取决于猫？是的，这是一个非常复杂的问题。这不是一个简单的问题，因为它取决于我们采取什么视角。如果我们通过猫福利的视角来看待这个问题，那么我会说，允许猫到户外去符合猫的最大利益。现在，无论是自由漫游还是以受控方式，比如用背带和牵引绳，或者在猫笼里，除了自由漫游之外还有其他选择。但猫，就福利而言，它们需要能够参与对它们来说自然的活动。
side. I think one of the things that I noticed found very intriguing in the documentary inside the mind of a cat was that description of the slow blink that you might use to communicate with cats. What is that? What are they responding to? Why should people do that? How should you best approach a cat? Yeah. So the slow blink is this idea that when you close your eyes very slowly and then open them slowly, you're kind of signaling to your cat that you're in a content mood and that potentially your cat is reading that as if it's a bonding moment. So your cat may slow blink back at you. Now, there's not been a lot of research on this besides work showing that cats that slow blinked, I believe, were more likely to be adopted from the shelter. So we don't really know a whole lot
猫四处走动并巡逻它们的区域、气味标记、抓挠、闻不熟悉的东西、观察动物和猎物，这些对猫来说都是自然的。所以让它们在某种程度上到户外去很重要。但就像你刚才说的，这是一个复杂的问题，因为它们是捕食者。它们影响我们的本地野生动物种群。而且对于猫本身来说，这可能很危险。有汽车。有其他的猫。
about that communication style, but there does seem to be something to it, at least on the human end, responding to that slow blink from the cat. But in terms of approaching them, you really want to be slow, kind of exactly like you talked about with the dog. You don't want to approach from overhead. You want to go slow. Let them sniff you before even touching them for cats and dogs olfaction is a really big sense. So they want to be able to smell you. They might rub you. And that that's really a key is kind of letting the cat dictate the interaction so instead of you know oh a cat picking them up and starting to pet them you know put your hand out let them smell it see if they rub against it if so give them a pet on the head see how they react um a lot of cats will go for that and they might
有其他物种对它们构成威胁。所以与此同时，从健康的角度来看，让它们到户外去可能对它们的福利有害。所以这确实是一种平衡行为。但我会说，我总是建议猫主人以某种方式让它们的猫出去。不一定是自由漫游，而是通过猫笼、散步，甚至只是一个窗台，它们可以坐在窗边闻到户外的气息。这对猫的心理健康非常重要。让我们谈谈猫的训练。
flop over and solicit for more petting but other cats might respond by backing away and that's a sign that they're done with the interaction so much of this is kind of again getting at that individual variation and seeing how that individual cat responds to the interaction in adjusting your behavior and response. So I have a question for you that comes from one of my colleagues at the APA who grew up in England. She says that growing up, the general feeling was that it was kinder to let cats have the freedom to roam outdoors. But here in the U.S., many people think it's better to keep cats indoors because it's safer and it also protects our dwindling songbird population. Is there a right answer? Is it better for the cat to be an indoor cat, an outdoor cat,
你如何训练猫停止你不喜欢的行为，比如，正如我在介绍中所说的，如何阻止它们抓你的沙发，并专注于你给它们买的抓板？对。是的，实际上，研究表明，通常不当抓挠行为的最大指标是主人家里没有给猫准备抓板，或者没有把抓板放在合适的位置。所以我经常和主人交谈，他们的猫在抓沙发，他们受够了。我问他们，好吧，你有猫爬架吗？他们说有。然后我问，那么猫爬架在哪里，猫用它吗？他们会说，哦，它在地下室的角落里，不，猫从来不用它。嗯，我们知道猫喜欢在社会重要区域周围进行气味标记。所以沙发就是一个完美的例子。每个人都在沙发上休息。沙发上有很多气味。
does it just depend on the cat? Yeah, this is a really complex issue. And it's not really an easy question because it kind of depends what perspective we take. If we look at this through the lens of cat welfare, then I would say that it's in the cat's best interest to be allowed to go outside. Now, whether that's free roaming or in a contained way, such as on harness and leash, or in a cat enclosure that there are options besides just free roaming. But cats, in terms of welfare, they need to be able to engage in behaviors that are natural to them.
所以猫只是试图通过抓挠，把它们的气味添加到这个社会重要区域。如果它们的猫爬架一直在地下室，它们是不会去那里使用的。所以很大程度上是把它们移动到对猫来说合适的位置。所以如果猫就在沙发旁边抓，把猫爬架移到沙发旁边，然后在它们使用猫爬架时表扬你的猫，用猫薄荷给它增加气味，在上面放零食。有多种方法可以让你把猫重新引导到那个区域去抓挠。所以这是我的主要建议。
It's natural for a cat to walk around and patrol their area, to scent mark, to scratch, to smell unfamiliar things, to watch animals and prey animals. So it is important for them to get outside at some level. But like you just said, it's a complex issue because they are predators. They impact our native wildlife populations. And also for the cats themselves, it can be dangerous. There's cars. There's other cats.
你真的不需要训练你的猫不去抓。更多的是关于训练它们将那种抓挠行为重新引导到不同的位置。那么训练猫做把戏呢，如果用一个更好的词的话？我们谈到过的你参与的Netflix特别节目，它介绍了两位猫训练师，他们可以训练猫做惊人的事情，比如跳过纸覆盖的圆环。那些只是不寻常的猫吗？还是任何人都可以训练猫做这些事，如果他们理解了激励猫的正确方法？
There's other species that pose risks to them. So at the same time, it can be damaging to their welfare to let them outside from a health perspective. So it's really kind of this balancing act. But I will say that I always suggest cat owners get their cats out in some way. It does not have to be free roaming. but through a cat enclosure, through walking, or even just a window ledge where they can sit at the window and smell the outdoors. That's going to be really important for the cat's mental health. Let's talk a little bit about cat training.
我认为两者都有。你知道，回到猫的个体差异，就像人一样。有些猫比其他猫学得快。有些猫可能比其他猫更有兴趣参与训练。所以这很大程度上是个性化的。但就猫的实际能力而言，所有的猫，除非有什么
How do you train a cat to stop a behavior that you don't like, say, as I said in the intro, like how to stop them from scratching your couch and focusing on the scratching post you got them? Right. Yeah, actually, research has shown that typically the biggest indicator of inappropriate scratching behavior is just the owner not having a scratching post in the house for the cat or not having that scratching post in an appropriate location. And so I'll talk to owners a lot of the time where their cat is scratching on the couch and they're fed up. I ask them, okay, do you have a cat tree? They say yes. And then I ask, well, where is the cat tree and does the cat use it? And they'll say, oh, it's in the basement in the corner and no, the cat never uses it. Well, we know that cats like to scent mark around socially important areas. So the couch is a perfect example. Everyone's hanging out on the couch. There's a lot of smells on the couch.
某种健康问题，所有的猫都应该能够使用狗学习的、人类学习的、所有动物学习的相同的学习过程来学习。所以没有理由认为大多数人不能用各种猫进行某种基本水平的训练。我的意思是，猫一直在向你学习，即使你没有主动训练它们。训练只是，你知道，条件反射原理的直接应用。所以猫一直在从它们的环境中学习，无论我们是否在主动训练
So the cat's just trying to, you know, add their smell to this socially important area by scratching. And if their cat towers all the way in the basement, they're not going to go down there and use it. So a lot of it is about moving those to appropriate locations for the cat. So if the cat is scratching right next to these are on the sofa, move the cat tower next to the sofa and then praise your cat when they do use the cat tower, scent it with catnip, you know, put treats on it. There are multiple ways that you can then redirect your cat to that area to scratch. So that's my major suggestion.
它们。所以我确实相信大多数猫都能学习，但并非所有的猫都能学会做那些复杂的、非常基于敏捷性的事情，这可能是一个取决于个性的特征。为什么猫可能对我们为它们买的那些昂贵的玩具毫无兴趣，但它们会花几个小时玩一个盒子或纸袋？我的意思是，我们还有必要给它们买玩具吗，还是只给它们袋子和盒子就行了？你知道，我完全经历过同样的事情。是的，我认为部分原因是这种观点，特别是对于只在室内的猫，它们的环境没有太大的变化。所以当像地板中间的一个盒子这样的新东西出现时，它就像是，哦，这里有一个我将要查看的新颖的丰富物品。所以我认为对这些东西的迷恋部分是因为它们的环境发生了变化。
you don't really need to train your cat not to scratch. It's more about training them to redirect that scratching behavior to a different location. What about training cats to do tricks, for lack of a better word? The Netflix special that we've talked about a little bit that you participated in, it profiled two cat trainers who could train cats to do amazing things like jumping through a paper-covered hoop. Were those just unusual cats? Or is there something that anybody could do with a cat to train them? if they understood the proper way to motivate a cat?
我经常讲这个故事。但有一次我和我丈夫要去海滩，我们拿出了我们的冷藏箱，把它放在地板中间，你知道，打包。但我们离开房间回来时，我们的两个男孩在冷藏箱里，闻着冷藏箱周围，调查它。现在是因为它们喜欢冷藏箱，还是因为它是它们环境中的新奇事物？所以我认为这是主人应该记住的事情。这不是关于拥有世界上所有最好的猫玩具。而是关于提供轮换的东西，让猫的环境保持有趣。我要问你一个可能不公平的问题。我甚至不确定
I think it's a little of both. You know, coming back to that individuality of cats, it's just like people. Some cats are faster learners than others. Some cats might be more interested in engaging in training than others. So a lot of that is personality-based. But in terms of the actual capabilities of cats, all cats, unless there is something,
它是可测量的，但猫比狗更聪明还是更不聪明？或者我们甚至应该尝试比较这两个物种吗？我不认为我们应该比较。再说一次，智力确实是个体特征。所以我不知道将整个物种相互比较是否公平。你知道，有不同的聪明方式。所以我认为把这些物种对立起来并不公平。你知道，我们可以说，嗯，人类显然比狗更聪明，比猫更聪明。但这真的对我们有什么帮助吗？
some kind of health issue going on, all cats should be able to learn using these same learning processes that dogs learn from, that humans learn from, that all animals learn from. And so there's no reason that we shouldn't think that most people could do some basic level of training with every kind of cat. I mean, cats are always learning from you, even if you're not actively training them. Training is just, you know, the direct application of conditioning principles. So cats are always learning from their environment, whether we're actively training.
这真的能帮助我们更好地回答关于我们动物行为的任何问题吗？所以我认为相反，我们应该欣赏个体物种的个体特征。再说一次，认识到在物种内部，有个体存在。所以我们不能做出这种笼统的陈述，说所有的狗都是一种方式，所有的猫都是一种方式。我们真的必须观察这些物种内部的个体。所以在阅读你的工作时，我看到你在Snopes.com的一篇文章中被引用，关于为什么猫喜欢坐在笔记本电脑上。我想很多听众可能很好奇，为什么猫会那样做？是的。嗯，老实说，我不记得我说了什么。所以希望我在这里说的是同样的事情。
them or not. So I do believe most cats can learn, but whether all cats can learn to do those complex, very agility-based things is probably going to be a personality-dependent trait. And why is it that cats might have no interest in those expensive toys we buy for them, but they'll spend hours playing with a box or a paper bag? I mean, should we even bother buying them toys and just give them bags and boxes? You know, I have totally experienced that exact same thing. Yeah, I think Part of it is this idea that, especially for indoor only cats, they don't have a lot of change to their environment. And so when something new comes like a box in the middle of the floor, it's kind of like, oh, this novel enrichment item here that I'm going to check out. So I think some of that fascination with those things is just the fact there's been a change to their environment.
但可能有几个原因。一个是，你知道，笔记本电脑很暖和。所以显然它是一个温暖的区域，可以过来待着。但另一个是，你知道，作为人，我们不断地将注意力集中在这些电脑和笔记本电脑上。所以这可能是一种猫的方式，比如，嘿，它们在，你知道，拟人化一点，你知道，我的人总是看着这个物体。所以如果我睡在这里，你知道，嘿，也许我会得到一些关注。所以那里可能发生了一些条件反射，猫来到电脑旁边，它们从人那里得到关注，因为它们总是在周围。可能是类似的事情。但我不能确定为什么猫会这样做。
And I tell this story a lot. But one time my husband and I were going to the beach and we pulled out our cooler and said, it in the middle of the floor to, you know, pack it. But we leave the room and come back and our two boys are in the cooler, smelling all around the cooler, investigating it. Now is it because they love coolers or because it was something novel in their environment? So I think that's something owners should keep in mind. It's not about having like all the best cat toys in the world. It's about providing a rotation of things to keep the environment interesting for the cat. I'm going to ask you something that maybe is unfair. And I'm not even sure that
你自己一直养猫吗？你从你自己的猫的行为中得到过任何研究想法吗？哦，是的。我从小到大一直养猫。这确实是我想要做这件事的原因，养猫并真正体验到我的猫对待我的方式与我听到的许多这些刻板印象不一致。所以这促使我开始问这些关于猫的问题。
that it's measurable, but are cats more or less intelligent than dogs? Or should we even try to compare the two species? I don't think we should compare. Again, intelligence is really an individual trait. And so I'm not sure that comparing an entire species against one another is fair. You know, there are different ways of being intelligent. And so I think it's not really fair to pit these species against each other. You know, we could say, well, humans are obviously more intelligent than dogs and more intelligent than cats. But what does that really do for us?
所以，是的，我一生都养猫。目前我有三个男孩。所以对不起，有什么，哦，它们是否帮助推动了一些研究问题。是的，是的，只是观察它们作为你的宠物，这给你想要研究更多的事情提供了想法。哦，绝对。我一直在看着它们，观察它们的行为并提出问题。它们也帮助充当豚鼠。所以如果我们正在考虑新的测试方法，
Does that really help us, you know, better answer any questions about our animals' behavior? So I think instead we should appreciate individual species for their individual traits. And again, recognize that within species, there's individuals. So we can't make these blanket statements that all dogs are one way. all cats are one way. We really have to look at the individuals within those species. So in reading up on your work, I saw you were quoted in a snopes.com article about why cats like to sit on laptops. And I think a lot of listeners might be curious to why do cats do that? Yeah. Well, honestly, I don't remember what I said. So hopefully I'll say the same thing here.
我可能会先在我的猫身上运行它，看看效果如何。所以，是的，它们总是以某种方式参与。一个有趣的事情，再次出现在那部Netflix纪录片中，我想是一位生理学家在谈论猫的呼噜声。呼噜声的声音不知何故体现了同样的噪音，同样的噪音水平，我们听到的
But there could be a few reasons. One is, you know, laptops are warm. So obviously it's, a warm area to come hang out. But another is that, you know, we're constantly as people directing our attention to these computers and laptops. And so it could be a way that the cat's like, hey, they're, you know, to anthropomorphize a bit, you know, my, my person is always looking at this object. So if I sleep here, you know, hey, maybe I'll get some attention. So there could be some kind of conditioning going around that where the cat comes over by the computer and they get attention from the person because they're always around. It could be something like that. but I can't say for sure why cats do it.
来自婴儿的哭声。你研究过那个吗？那是合法的吗？因为，你知道，
Have you always had cats yourself and have you gotten any research ideas from your own cats behaviors? Oh yeah. I've had cats my whole life since I was a little kid. And that was really what got me into wanting to do this was owning cats and really experiencing that the way that my cats behaved toward me wasn't aligned with a lot of these stereotypes I heard. and so that kind of pushed me to start asking these questions about cats.
当你听到猫呼噜时，它在它们的喉咙深处，看起来一点也不像婴儿哭的声音。是的。所以我个人没有进行过那项研究，但我很熟悉它。他谈论的是一种被称为请求呼噜的特定呼噜声。所以发生的事情是，你有你通常描述的低音呼噜。但会发生的是有一个高频成分，这就是作者描述它的方式。麦库姆是这项研究的作者，基本上它有点像一个，我甚至不知道怎么描述它，像一个像喵喵叫的类型。它不是喵喵叫。去搜索请求呼噜，因为有一个片段，但它基本上是那个低音呼噜，上面有一个更高频率
And so, yeah, I've always had cats my whole life. And currently I have three boys right now. So I'm sorry, was there's, oh, whether they helped push some research questions. Yeah, yeah, just observing them as your pets are that give you ideas for things you want to study more. Oh, definitely. I'm always looking at them and observing their behavior and asking questions. and they also help serve as guinea pigs. So if we're thinking of new testing methodology,
的发声。它听起来更像早期的。这是研究人员发现的。人们认为这是一种非常紧急的呼噜声。他们发现猫经常在请求食物或需要什么东西时这样做。所以那个高频成分就是他谈论的那个方面，它与婴儿的哭声频率相同。所以是的，那是一项非常有趣的研究，因为它有点回到我们的依恋研究，似乎有一种哺乳动物的倾向，不仅是对这些高频发声做出反应，而且还能形成依恋。这正是我们在狗和猫身上看到的。所以非常
I might run it on my cats first to see how it goes. So, yeah, they're always participating in some way. One interesting thing that came out, again, in that Netflix documentary was, I think he was a physiologist who was talking about cats purr. And the sound of a purr somehow embodies the same noise, the same level of noise that we're hearing. from a baby's cry. Have you looked into that? And it was that legitimate? Because, you know,
有趣的研究，它有点结合在一起，猫与人的这种关系非常类似于后代与父母的关系，但显然是在两个不同的物种之间。那么关于猫，你还在寻求回答的大问题是什么？你现在在做什么？所以现在我正在与莫妮克·尤德尔博士和俄勒冈州立大学的其他同事合作，我们正在对猫和有发育障碍的儿童进行动物辅助干预。所以基本上我们正在观察，如果孩子们带着他们的猫来到俄勒冈州立大学并参加为期六周的课程，对孩子或猫有什么变化吗？所以这是我们目前正在进行的一个项目，非常有趣，我期待看到结果如何。嗯，我要
when you hear a cat purr, it's like very deep inside of their throat and doesn't seem at all akin to the sound of a baby crying. Yeah. So I have not personally conducted that research, but I'm familiar with it. And what he is talking about is a specific kind of per known as the solicitation per. So what happens is you have your typically low-pitched per that you're describing. But what will happen is there's a high frequency component and this is how the authors describe it. McComb is the author of this where basically it's kind of like a I don't even know how to describe it like a like a meow type. It's not a meow. Go go search solicitation per after this because there is a clip of it but it's basically that low pitch per with a higher frequency
感谢你今天参加我的节目。这真的很有趣。太棒了。非常感谢你的邀请。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢你的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
vocalization over top of it. And it sounds a lot more early. is what the researchers found. People perceive this as being a very urgent sounding per. And they find that cats often do it when they're soliciting for food or when they need something. And so that high frequency component is the aspect that he was talking about that is at the same frequency as an infant's cry. So yeah, that was a really interesting study because it kind of goes back to our attachment research where it appears there's kind of this, um, mammalian predisposition to not only respond to these high-frequency vocalizations, but also to form attachments. And that's exactly what we're seeing in dogs and cats as well. So very
在它之上叠加发声。研究人员发现，这听起来更像早期的声音。人们认为这是一种听起来非常急促的呼噜声。他们发现猫通常在索要食物或需要什么东西时会发出这种声音。所以他所说的高频成分，正是与婴儿哭声频率相同的那个部分。所以，是的，那是一项非常有趣的研究，因为它有点回到了我们的依恋研究，即哺乳动物似乎不仅对这些高频发声有反应，而且还会形成依恋。这正是我们在狗和猫身上所看到的。所以非常
interesting research, and it kind of all goes together that this relationship that cats have with people is very akin to an offspring parent relationship, but obviously between two different species. So what are the big questions about cats that you are still looking to answer? What are you working on now? So right now I am collaborating with Dr. Monique Udell and some other colleagues at Oregon State University and we're doing animal assisted interventions with cats and children with developmental disabilities. So basically we're looking at if children come into OSU with their cat and go through a six-week course, are there any changes to the child or to the cat? So that's one project we have going on right now that is very interesting and I look forward to seeing how that turns out. Well, I want to
有趣的研究，这一切都表明猫与人之间的这种关系非常类似于后代与父母的关系，尽管显然是在两个不同的物种之间。那么，关于猫，你还有哪些想要回答的大问题？你现在在研究什么？目前，我正在与俄勒冈州立大学的莫妮克·尤德尔博士和其他同事合作，我们正在对猫和患有发育障碍的儿童进行动物辅助干预。基本上，我们正在观察如果孩子们带着他们的猫来到俄勒冈州立大学并参加为期六周的课程，孩子或猫是否会有任何变化？所以这是我们目前正在进行的一个非常有趣的项目，我很期待看到结果如何。嗯，我想
thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Great. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。太棒了。非常感谢你的邀请。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你收听播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。